[Music]
jerry can you watch the kids tonight
oh uh no we can't watch the kids it's
guys night not telling anyone else how
to pair him but why is beth even asking
jerry to watch the kids
summer's old enough to watch morty and
they've left the home alone before in
prior episodes
i'm just saying this feels like a purely
arbitrary way to get beth involved in
some hell-raising activities later on in
the show
also this dartboard location are you
sure that's where the grapes go morty
because i feel like they'd feel more at
home beside that [ __ ] fruit bowl
that we've seen before for being in a
ridiculous place in the living room and
we will keep sinning until they [ __ ]
remove it
and they're all crowning i have to go
show leaves the achieving the rare
triple crown joke in the stable
yeah most people would call that family
you're so you have to like it or you're
sexist that's
i'm not sure if this creature has a
tongue peen or a mouth china but either
way this pinging a dentata is getting a
sin
hey we're in luck gang they've got the
entire smash mouth catalog
smash mouth shaming what they had that
song you know the one there was
haying now and they couldn't get enough
of their baby and and
yeah they were putting your feet on your
eating surface
with shoes on is that classic snake boy
that guy just keeps getting bigger
commenting on bruce jetback snake dude
this [ __ ] plays it close to the vest
thinking running tap water will drown
out the sound of you talking about
someone in the next room
[Music]
also i just watched jurassic park on
cable explaining your references
you could be brilliant rick and morty
but you're a coward
black swan seriously though i'll freeze
your
amber so how exactly would that threat
stop summer from touching
which means rick is going to die because
of you unless you you go offline
this computes this computes
oh yeah as much as this bueller's on for
some time i'm surprised the title of
this episode wasn't rickus mortler's
rick day
off morty why would a mailbox society
live in buildings shaped like mailboxes
if it were a letter or package society
sure but do humans design houses that
look like giant humans
dogs maybe but not humans
going postal summer morty and shut back
survive this
why is it that whenever the smiths bring
some rando on one of these adventures
said rando is never freaking the [ __ ]
out
shut back should be backing his pants
right now or at the very least asking
how the [ __ ]
they're flying in space except i don't
get pleasure from mocking others because
i'm not
lame uh no sin here just
really great show being really great
i mean i'll have to add a sin or cindy
won't move on but
we're totally not lame next
what is that essence of hell how did
they get this drinker these cups they
didn't have any of this on them when
they entered through the hell
gate i'm not sure what's going on here
but i am sure that morty needs more
water intake
looks like he's peeing orange juice i
hope it's at least pulp free
what the hell bruh thing i say every
time there's more than three clasps to
undo somehow makes it into the episode
why would i
actually yes it does it's a car i
am a car not a robot wrong you're both a
robot's simply a computer that can
transport itself and do tasks which
you can you could have said you aren't
an android since that has more of a
human connotation or you could have said
you aren't a change former
since that has more of a don't sue us i
swear they aren't transformers
connotation
isn't a doorknob a virgin not mine
what do you expect i mean she's my why
i almost want to take a sent off for the
show pointing out that borat isn't all
that funny but then again this made me
think of how unfunny borat is and that
irritated me so
jerry's the best talking about someone
in the bathroom not realizing said
someone is in the stalling near
everything being said cliche
also how did they not realize jerry was
in the bathroom these two were outside
when he said he had to go pee
after a week rife with a fetter of sin i
yearn
for a taste of his cringe sitting
episodes of the office
casually dining while face peeled hell
spawn are around
this is gonna lose this place at least
one of its michelin stars remember beth
is just a cartoon remember beth is just
a cartoon remember better
also there's not nearly explanation
enough for how rick has created these
outfits
is beth really bleeding did they stop at
a costume store does rick really have a
hole in his midsection now
is he wearing a marlin a marlin there's
no marlins in baseball
i mean hell oh it's painful so i love it
this pleasure equals pain equals
pleasure diatribe goes on for
all the some time i think the statute of
sanitations is about up on sending rick
and morty producing complex devices out
of thin air like this arm cannon so in
order not to let it slip by i'll just
point out that something can't come from
nothing
something has to come from something and
you can yell nano technology all you
want and it still doesn't make it any
less of a cheat
zippers near genitals and yes i'm aware
most pants already have this
it was always a bad idea see cringe
cannot exist
in a vacuum it needs to be observed the
tv sins motto somehow makes its way into
this episode
like what i did with the chip in her
head is she gonna be okay
summer is concerned about not allison
hannigan but not the cindy and alien
mailboxes she obliterated earlier
could this be the end of mouse trapping
me opposed i mean one can help but
because of wiki fan pages and
fan fiction i'm guessing not
sorry i farted the rare fart joke
bookends
look when you bookend with back end i
gotta get some respect
and by respect i mean sins
we have such sights to show you
i'd like to ask you a few questions
we're touching rick's stuff summer he
said no
please god damn it i hate this hacking
crap low-life
butt-based miscreant butt-face miscreant
what if sydney killed casey and steve
why would she do that
maybe she has the hots for steve to kill
them both in the chat's range
you're just moody you got stuck with the
marlins
give me that fish nerds